all right i'm laura ingram this is
ingram angle from washington tonight
the climate con trolls that's the focus
of tonight's angle
now all the enlightened people you know
who they are they now insist that summer
is no longer supposed to be hot so any
heat wave anywhere by its very existence
is evidence of climate change so they're
all reading from the same playbook with
the end game more obvious by the day the
climate propaganda it's saturating the
airwaves
yes it's summer yes it's supposed to be
hot but it has never been like this
dallas and oklahoma city reached 109
degrees today
again this is a global problem just look
at the heat map
mexico central america this heat
devastation is evidence as if you need
more of it that climate change is here
and is a crisis what scientists and
activists have been warning about for
decades
we knew these temperatures were coming
we might not have known 2022 but we knew
they were coming
was that guy a phd i think he writes for
the new york times i don't know but
remember they never have to establish
actual facts it's all kind of i don't
know just a feeling
we are feeling it we're literally
feeling it we are enduring the effects
of climate change
feeling it of course the truth about
global warming is never as simple as
they claim
so showing this really scary looking
temperature map with a bunch of red on
it ignores another expert analysis
the worst heat waves on our planet
aren't happening now they actually
occurred 40 years ago according to
review by researchers from the
university of bristol in the united
kingdom
we show there have been some even
greater extremes in the last few decades
said vicki thompson a climate scientist
at the university of bristol and lead
author of this new paper
and notice by the way that the climate
controls wailing about how this is the
worst heat wave ever don't acknowledge
what happened in europe almost two
decades two decades ago
35 000 people died because of what
extreme heat
yet the left and its media allies they
want strict government controls on how
business operates and eventually
on how we as free citizens live
so it's just more fodder for liberals to
call for the senate to be abolished as
this writer for the new york times
argued today
because they blather on about extreme
heat
how about their extreme solutions
like blowing up the constitution so they
can sidestep the red states altogether
or force americans out of their cars the
cars that they love into cars they don't
want and can't afford
which brings us to the beaver cleaver of
the biden cabinet
mayor pete
today he made an admission about high
gas prices
of course the more pain we are all
experiencing from the high price price
of gas the more benefit there is for
those who can access electric vehicles
never has the worth of a rhodes
scholarship been so called into question
he apparently hadn't ever pondered the
obvious question
so if everyone switches to evs
what happens to the grid
congressman tom massey schooled little
pete
i'm really alarmed
at sort of the naivete
of those who are
promoting rapid adoption of these
technologies with our existing
infrastructure over the course of a year
an american household would use 25 times
as much
electricity for their electric cars they
would for their refrigerator
do you think it would strain the grid if
everybody plugged in 25 refrigerators in
every household well if we didn't make
any upgrades to the grid sure i mean if
we had yesterday's grid with tomorrow's
cars it's not going to work
literally biden has the dumbest cabinet
in u.s history zero common sense if that
average household plugged in electric
cars
do you know how much more electricity
they would use in comparison to the air
conditioning that air conditions their
whole house no but again i would
emphasize it would take four times as
much electricity to charge the average
households cars as the average household
uses on air conditioning
now air conditioning that's another
thing on the climate controls chopping
block these passive men think that you
should be happy with passive cooling
an assistant professor at the university
of oregon says that passive cooling is
so promising because it's less expensive
it averts intensification of urban heat
island effects it increases
survivability by diminishing reliance on
air conditioning
and forget a return to american energy
glut the independence we enjoyed cnn's
answer to living through a heat wave
includes these helpful hints
close your blinds and sleep in the
basement
got it
is that what it's come to as we told you
last night lowering your standard of
living and your expectations for the
future they are the goals here this
isn't happening by accident they're
inflicting this necessary pain on you
they believe it's necessary it's a
sacrifice you should make
in the list of what the climate trolls
demand to take from you to save the
planet that keeps growing of course we
also know that of course the gas powered
cars they want that out they want
non-smart thermostats gone they want to
diminish farmland
beef and other livestock they want that
out fertilizer want to control that
generators they don't like your
generators discretionary travel no not
so much leaf blowers they've always
hated those gas ranges
and gas heat all right you think i'm
joking right about gas ranges
well in dozens of counties on the east
on the west coast where the climate
controls are most influential they have
already banned natural gas in
residential homes and now the nation's
capital is set to become the second east
coast city to ban gas boilers and water
heaters
now
this is absolute madness it's going to
drive up the cost of home heating for
those who can least afford it
but of course the trolls they don't care
they never did
they use the voters then abuse the
voters they're horrible people
they know their climate con is about to
unravel and that americans are just
tired of being told to sacrifice as they
see china and india doing whatever they
damn well please on the climate stuff
fossil fuels forget about it they'll
burn them they don't care
so using fear and intimidation the
trolls want to speed up the transition
timeline before the voters have their
say in november
so you notice everything suddenly become
urgent everything's an emergency
the challenge that we're facing globally
on climate is is real and we need to
take whatever measures we can to
accelerate uh
all the work that we're doing to make
sure uh that we can address the the
climate emergency
okay dracula go back in the coffin what
they want is for you to travel less eat
less buy less use less heat use less ac
or not at all
now since congress won't pass new
climate rules they had to deal with joe
manchin right they want biden to declare
a climate emergency
that's a move that would give the
federal government extraordinary power
to take your freedom away just as they
did during covet
well in may 2021 the angle predicted
this
do you think the force is propping up
biden aren't thinking about declaring a
climate emergency in some form during
its first term
you haven't been paying close attention
of course the lockdowns gave them the
perfect road map for how to exert
control over the population
14 months ago to the day
same white dress no different white
dress all right and now biden's
traveling to massachusetts tomorrow to
push the griniak agenda he's throwing a
bone to the climate trolls but he's not
going as far as to declare that federal
climate emergency at least not yet
so this issue that's on the ballot in
most every state and federal election
across america
a vote for a democrat is a vote to rob
you of your freedom and your prosperity
even your preferred method of heating
your home or cooking your food
because if the climate trolls have their
way we are not going to recognize our
country anymore
so don't worry about a heat wave worry
about their control wave that's going to
wipe out what we love most about america
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else